to have here on the show for the first
time uh we're in year seven it's been
quite some time and uh thrilled to have
here
the academy award-winning actor he won
uh he won the trophy for his
fantastic work in manchester by the sea
he's got two films to talk about right
now
uh one he's in in both uh our friend
which is available now in select
theaters and on demand as well as the
world to come which
he stars in and produces that's
available in the middle of february and
then in early march
uh on digital um he is casey affleck how
are you sir
hello rich how are you thanks for having
me you bet uh appreciate you coming on
here let's uh let's talk a little sports
first
let's uh let's let's jump uh let's dive
in first are you uh i imagine
um big time boston sports fan is that a
fair assumption sir
that's a fair assumption i grew up in
boston uh i played sports my whole life
i still play sports i love them uh
i've worked i worked at fenway uh sports
have always been a big part of my life
so uh
um yeah patriots celtics red sox all
right so let's get into it
um working at fenway did you were you a
vendor is that what you're saying
i was a vendor man i started out i was
uh i was 13 years old and
um and i was playing on a baseball team
some older kids and
and uh those kids played on a travel
team with some coach who had a
had a stand at fenway his dad owned like
a vending business um
and they just thought it would be funny
i think to bring the younger kid along
you know we would go and work
you know after school you show up at
like three o'clock and you get ready and
you work the whole
crowd coming into the game and then the
crowd leaving so you're not home until
11 o'clock at night i don't know
you know my mom let me do this um made
pretty good money i worked a lot of
games
through uh like eighth grade
freshman year in high school um so
and in the middle of the games there'd
be everyone would be on the inside we
were on the outside
on lansdowne street and we would go into
the game
you know we'd give like sausages and hot
dogs to the kids the other guys who were
working this
uh turnstiles and they would let us in
for free and we'd go find seats so
i saw i don't know you know 100 games at
fenway
so uh basically what you're saying is uh
a patron wanting to put down their
hard-earned american dollars to see mike
greenwell and boggs and marty barrett
and spike owen go at it could have
bought a a hot dog from casey affleck is
that what you're saying
i'm sure they did yeah
the john mcnamara managed 1988 red sox
pretty much i'm trying to do the math in
my head right here
yeah those are the years like morgan
magic we got uh when
um uh he came in and and um
we won 20 home games in a row or
whatever and uh there's a lot of lee
smith i remember we worked right in
front of this bar
um called the cask and flag and of
course and uh
after the games you know we'd still be
cleaning up the crowds have gone
half the team would come out going to
the casket flag and
and the the dude i worked for who owned
the thing he would go in there too
and had a few pops and um those are that
was back in the day
people were rules were a little bit more
relaxed and and i would go in there and
just wait for my ride home you know i'm
sitting around at the bar and it's like
lee smith is having a few and um
that was a fun time i imagine so
man oh man oh man uh so what's your uh
feel watching tom brady do what he's
doing with gronk for another team
right now kcra i'm really happy for them
happy for both of them
i love it it's amazing if you can't
appreciate what brady's doing now
uh you just don't love sports i mean
it's um
it's just incredible so i'm rooting for
them um
and uh and gronk too and uh
i mean i think that they're gonna be
wishing they had brought along uh stefan
gilmore
um in the next game it's gonna be it's
gonna be tough for them
um but i i i've got faith yeah i'm sure
i mean um
and and i know um your die hard uh
you said boston sports fan uh i'm
wondering if uh
if this uh voice rings a bell from back
in the deflategate uh era
from about uh six seven years ago go for
it mike i talk to
football players pro football players
across the board
they think it's does that name is that
uh voice ring a bell to you
casey i recognize that empirical rant
yeah do you speak to football players
talking about the fake gate come on
no i'm just let it go no no i'm just
wondering if you speak to football
players across the board as much as your
brother
does all the guys i talked to in the nfl
that's our we've been playing that sound
by drop for for several years because i
i just love he's just he was into it man
and and
and that's the passion of the boston
sports fan as you know is that you you
just back your guys
and that's it and the story you know
that's right and and tommy gross still
feel like
our guys i don't i don't begrudge them
for moving on
you gotta you gotta go find uh new
places to grow
and you need to grow so um i'm rooting
for them and i
you know we noticed as well casey uh
that you have thrown out of first pitch
at fenway park
and we've now established that uh you
grew up in that building what in the
world was that like for you
to do that that was that was incredible
man i wish i had warmed up a little bit
i got a better arm than that
but um you know that that was really
that was really an honor just just
bizarre are you saying you didn't throw
a strike what happened
what happened i don't think i threw a
strike uh i i didn't get
i didn't get the it was uh it was in the
dirt
look but here's the thing here's the
thing the it's good that i don't know
the answer to it casey because if you
had if you had
done something horribly wrong that lives
on youtube for absolutely ever
so the fact that i don't know whether
you threw a strike means that you were
you were
serviceable enough i i did one once in
dodger stadium
and the thing that you don't know is
that you you have to throw the ball
up in the air you feel like when you're
on the mound because i'm assuming you
did do it from the mound right because
you're real your real deal
so yeah you're not going to do it you're
not going to just stand in front of the
mound and throw it you're going to do it
from the
you're going to do it from the rubber
and the whole thing is that you if you
throw it down that's when you dirt it
mine would have uh fooled a left-hander
but hit a right-handed batter that's
what my pitch would have done
you know um it's true you know i guess
uh i didn't end up on youtube and um
that like 50 cent or somebody it wasn't
embarrassing
it was it was close but um you know
i've gotten more into sports and at the
the older i get and
obviously the harder it is to play and
uh the fewer places there are to
you know let me play but um i just i
just love it it's become a bigger and
bigger part of my life i wish i had
just given my all to being a
professional athlete somehow
um i got a friend who says that we can
if we could hack beyond sides kick
somehow we
might still be able to we could
volunteer for
for a professional football team if we
could just figure out how to do that one
thing somehow
um but other than that i don't have a i
don't stand a chance in hell being able
to
actually play but i played a baseball
team out in in la and
um that's been a lot of fun we started
that like 10 years ago and i know you
had
john hamm on your show yes uh hand plays
on our club
and um club i love it he plays in your
club
okay yeah he's uh he's pretty good and
um
okay and uh we have uh we have a lot of
fun so it's kind of worth it you get
into your 40s and
it's um i mean we start i started this
sort of ten years ago so
so what do you play where do you play
out there what do you play
i play third hot corner first yep hot
corner
so ham plays first so if you're scoring
at home it's
it's uh the the five three put out is
is affleck to ham is that what you're
saying
like you know it hasn't been called on
the radio that way yet
it's my job to say things that way i'm
sorry i slip right into it casey i can't
help myself
i can't help myself yeah so that's it
five three that's the put out you're the
hot corner man
anybody else that we know on your team
uh
well one time we played with um matt
moore the quarterback of the he was then
playing in
in miami okay uh we go up and play at uh
san quentin we'll take the team up to
the the prison and san quentin
will play ball up there and um you know
uh
it's it's a great experience that they
have their own baseball team and
uh so they love having guys from the
outside come in and play them
and uh we were short a couple guys one
year um
some guys just didn't get cleared you
gotta like you know make sure you don't
have a record and stuff and so
um we went up there and we a friend
uh knew matt moore and so he invited him
up and um
you know the the guys in san quentin got
a real kick out of that when they
realized who he was
um and uh i don't know who else
we had a guy we have a guy who played
with the mets is one of our best
pitchers
you know when we went to saint clinton
man it was the most amazing experience
because this is the first year and you
go up and you they just put you out in
the yard
uh there's nobody with you they just say
look we don't you know sign a paper that
says you understand we don't negotiate
for hostages
and go on in there get out of here are
you serious seriously
and so you do we get and we it's like
eight in the morning or something 7
30 when they put everyone out there so
we go in we play two double headers
uh we play a double header play two
games so the little sort of lunch break
in between and
when the guys have to go back into their
cells and be counted then they come back
out
and the first game uh you know we beat
him
and um we went back in there for the
second game and these guys
they were they were upset you know some
of them knew who i was a little bit
but i just generally knew we were like
these guys come up from l.a
um and they really wanted to win
and um it was like one of those
situations
you imagine when you're a kid in the
backyard and you sort of like paint the
picture for some at that
it was the this was the the last inning
and uh we were up by three they were the
home team
obviously so uh we had our best picture
on the map
there was two outs with bases loaded
and a full count and a guy hits a walk
off grand slam
out of saint clinton to win the game and
they went
crazy i mean it was like they were so
so happy um the celebration lasted
20 minutes and then um so that just felt
great that was the best feeling i've
ever had losing a baseball no
kidding oh my gosh so i don't know
i'm like is this it's like stir crazy
like or the baseball version of the
longest yard in a way that you're going
up there and you're
you're playing against these guys and a
double header
you beat them in the so it's just they
took the night cap is basically what
you're saying
yeah this thing man what a story and
it's it feels it feels great for them
you can tell how much it means to them
to be able to go play ball i mean a lot
of them were athletes
there was a guy there was a shortstop um
he had been scouted by the indians in
the royals when he was 18 years old
he was an incredible athlete he had
gotten into the
car with a friend who had committed her
murder that same night earlier and he
didn't know it uh he
and so he was arrested as an accomplice
to murder
uh when the police pulled the car over
later um and when we played
with him a few years ago um
he had been in prison for 15 years oh my
god and he missed his window to play
uh professional ball so then the next
year he made parole and he was out
casey affleck here on the rich eisen
show let's talk about your movies here
i'll make that hill turn
uh our friend is really intense sir i
mean it's based on a
story in esquire where um
you you play the uh husband who's losing
his wife to
cancer she's been diagnosed terminally
and jason siegel plays a friend that
comes in to try and help
um in a very difficult spot in the
situation beautiful movie
sir why did you want to make it why'd
you want to do it
you know i i like the story i like the
people involved that are making the
movie
um yeah it's just a it's just a movie
about people showing up for one another
when it's really hard
uh it sort of reaffirms the
great and sometimes forgotten value of
friendship uh and i like that message
um you know this guy jason siegel's
character
it's true stories are all real people
and i don't really know them but
you know based on what people say about
them and what was the research the the
writer did i
i feel like i do and siegel's
character's got his life is really
is empty and my life is in crisis and
uh he drops everything he shows up for
me and
so it's sort of ha it supported that old
adage that
you know if you need a friend be a
friend uh
and i thought like that's a that's a
pretty good message you shot in fair
hope alabama where the real story where
the real
that's where the real story took place
too right yeah yeah
huh that is just really i mean
um man you do some deep intense movies
uh i mean this is it is it a choice
that you you do this casey i mean they
won't let me do comedies
they've i've i've tried and they just
won't let you do it huh
i mean they just as much funny you want
to be in the comedy
you're going to have to be funny um i
don't know
i like some of these yeah i'm drawn to
these to dramas i guess
um but they're not the movies i watch
you know when i'm sitting at home i'm
i'm putting on world war z and uh you
know moneyball and
tapping out yeah uh-huh and then the
world to come you you produce this
as well uh takes place in the 19th
century uh
in the northeast of our of our country
and i'll give you the floor on why you
wanted to produce this and
what people should uh check out february
12th in theaters and then on
digital on march 2nd you know i did a
movie called the assassination of jesse
james
uh by the howard robert ford and the guy
who wrote that book became a friend of
mine i was based on a book and um
ron hanson and i asked him you got
anything other stories you want to tell
and
he sent me two and one was about this
cuban uh baseball player in the in the
60s and i
you know i'd been to cuba when i was a
kid um
and i loved baseball i thought this was
perfect and then i read the second one
it was about
two women on a farm in the 19th century
who fall in love
and i had never been a woman on a farm
in the 19th century i didn't know
a lot about it but it was really moving
story and um
i just i just loved it and i said okay
let's do that one and
he and uh jim sheppard another uh writer
they wrote the
script together and it took about six
years or something and um
you know i don't know why by why i
always pick pick movies but
uh it's usually just if i read it and it
and it uh
i love it you know either i think it's
funny or it's exciting or it's moving or
something and so
that one we went and got um captain mars
and vanessa kirby two
great actors and uh they star in it and
um
it's a beautiful little movie you and
christopher abbott as well again it's
called the world to come and everybody
should check it out on february 12th
digitally on march 2nd and our friend is
available uh
now in select theaters and on demand
before i let you go i just want to do a
couple quick hitters on some of your
other
uh films that you were in casey is it
true is it true
that all your lines in good will hunting
are ad-libbed there were no lines for
you
in that you ad-lib them is that a true
story they had lines for me i just
didn't say them
there were written lines not many all
right believe me all the best lines that
you come up with they gave to themselves
right so how far off were your lines
from the
written page then casey i can't remember
i can't remember the written page
on that on that one um i had done a
couple movies
and i had worked with the guy who was
directing that guest van sant
um i had already worked them and i was
at school and i really wasn't
that interested in going leaving school
to go and make that movie kind of
sit sit around in the background in the
back seat of the car all those guys
played hero and um but they
they uh they kind of bullied me and and
so i did it and
that's why i just tried to ruin every
scene by making up my own dialogue no
kidding
you're real so there was uh how i guess
i should say how about them apples is
really what i should say right there i'm
sorry i i should
go nail that one uh and give me your
best ocean story
give me your best ocean story from that
set you got one i know you're laughing
because i don't know how many of you you
can
actually tell um but give me give me a
good one you know
what happens in the biggest days i've
heard of that yes yeah we we shot um
let's see the best uh best uh ocean
story i'd say is
uh radio friendly um
is that you know i had a kid my son was
born
on that movie uh that's hard to that's
hard to beat
uh on the second movie in amsterdam
we're shooting and
that's my first son was porn um that's
not the kind of story you were hoping
for
but um it was 2004 and my next
son was born in 2007. i don't know if
those years mean
anything to you um but i you're going
red socks on me there aren't you
okay damn it you're good rich so uh
um yeah i didn't have another kid in the
next time but
um well
i guess if you don't want any more
children it it it's good that mookie
betts is no longer on the team
you know what i heard man i listened to
that your interview with anthony mackie
i just thought it was really funny and i
worked with mackie and um you asked him
for his best story from
uh from uh whatever he did with him
eight mile
yeah that was a great story man it was
great well i had no idea
so i don't know if i i have no idea if
like uh
clooney came up with lines to give you
crap or or anything
so i guess let me let me ask you this
then uh did you guys like
play poker or whatever on the set or
anything go down i mean
i mean yeah i can't even really remember
being on the set all that i really
remember was the times afterward i mean
it was there was a lot of poker there's
a lot of hanging around
everyone's in the same hotel i mean we
shot the first one in las vegas
so i lived in the bellagio for i don't
know three months
i don't remember going outside that much
uh
you go into one of those casinos you
could you know
there could be an apocalypse happening
you wouldn't know just everything got
food anything you need is there
um i like one of the things i remember
is that the producer jerry wine traps
are a famous old movie producer
he really liked to take care of his big
stars which i was not
one of them uh so you know
there's 11 guys i was like number 11. um
but and it made me mad because i sort of
thought like why are these guys they
have all their food and their
you know their laundry anything anything
they need handle is handled
they have people already who can do that
they don't need they get all the money
in the world they can pay for their own
food
but every time i had to sign a check you
know at this casino
restaurant i was paying that bill man so
i just started got everyone else's room
number and i would just start signing
yes yes that went on for a
very long time the payback for that was
that
on the i guess it was the second movie
or some third movie or something i
showed up and um
this was jerry weintraub's idea of a
joke uh i barely even noticed but it was
uh
you know they had a you'd go to the set
of one of those movies there'd be like a
long line of 10 of these like luxury
trailers or everyone's you know between
their scenes they get to go hang out and
it's like bigger than my house
and there's uh ten of them and then
there's a little there's like a small
used tent that has been set up for me to
me to spend my time in
those sorts of things went on all the
time um
that was a good group of guys i don't
know if you've read don cheadle on the
show he's a great course
absolutely we've had him and you know
matt damon and um
you know uh i've i've and soderbergh
you know years ago when we were a
podcast before we were this show
we had stephen once we had him uh
be the media critic for a super bowl
like to just look at the super bowl and
talk about the play-by-play and the
broadcast and what it looked like
and it was dynamite as you might imagine
it was just he is truly one of the
greats ever
in just a brilliant mind and um i can't
say enough about him
yeah very very talented guy you know we
would shoot uh
be done by lunch most of the time that's
and i've never met anyone and then he
would be editing in the afternoon
kind of do it all and he played ball i
think in um
he played he played baseball in college
i think i can't remember where he went
but he was an athlete too i think he's a
carnegie mellon guy or something like
that i think he's a pittsburgh guy i
don't know off the top of my head but
anyway hey casey i appreciate the time
and the the conversation and uh let's do
this again
thank you thanks for having me man great
to talk to you right back at you
again our friend available now in select
theaters and on demand the world to come
available in theaters february 12th and
available on digital
tuesday march 2nd casey affleck hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here